Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13. Сегодня мы поговорим о абсолютно новом конгломерате браузерных отпечатков.
Мы с вами на предыдущих уроках уже изучили какие новые технологии, например, как WebAssembly,
либо же получение отпечатка с помощью WebGPU.
Но в этом году, в 2025 году, как ни странно, довольно большое количество новых технологий было представлено.
И этим летом была представлена технология, которая называется браузер FM.
Соответственно, документ вы сейчас видите на своих экранах.
Вы можете этот документ скачать по его названию, найти и ознакомиться с ним,
либо же вы можете скачать данный документ в приложении к данному видеоуроку на сайте DetectExpert.
Итак, что такое браузер FM?
Да не введет вас в заблуждение слово, точнее, слово-буква-сочетание FM.
Это не радио, это Future Model, сокращенно.
То есть браузер Future Model.
Что это такое?
На текущий момент это самый большой из существующих браузерных отпечатков.
Сейчас я вам расскажу, как он появляется и как он выглядит.
Выглядит он довольно просто.
Вот у меня подготовлена как раз страница чекера данного отпечатка.
И те, кто следил за каналом антидетект в Телеграме,
те наверняка уже ознакомились с данным отпечатком, поскольку я давал для него небольшой нонс.
Что делает данный отпечаток?
Давайте проверим.
Мы сейчас попробуем его на моем тесте.
Мой тест не полный, он усеченный.
Но попробуем выкрутить его на максимум.
И вот мы получаем наш отпечаток браузера и какие-то непонятные значения.
Что же это такое?
Сейчас произошла так называемая BOM-энумерация.
Сбор происходит путем обхода BrowserObjectModel.
Таких классов как Window, Navigator, Screen, Performance, CSS, GPT.
Иными словами, BrowserFM, BrowserFutureModel, технология позволяет считать 16 тысяч параметров с вашего компьютера.
С вашего браузера и вашего компьютера.
Но это довольно большое значение, согласитесь.
Если, например, раньше, когда мы работали с каким-то отпечатком, я вот помню, как сейчас, 2011 год,
когда можно было зарабатывать великолепно.
Деньги путем работы с AdSense с помощью Тора.
И тогда в Украину мне высылали, Google высылал по несколько чеков.
Тогда работали так, что Google высылал чеки, размер чека 100 долларов.
Высылались они автоматически, когда ты доходишь до порога 100 долларов.
И, соответственно, даже с обычного Тора в 2011 году можно было зарабатывать довольно-таки приличные деньги.
То есть, ну...
Тысяча долларов в день вообще не составляло никакого труда.
А сейчас, фактически каждый месяц мы имеем какую-то новую технологию, какие-то новые отпечатки.
И вот сейчас браузер FutureModel позволяет считать до 16 тысяч параметров с нашего ПК.
Затем происходит так называемое построение фьючер-модели дерева.
То есть...
Условно говоря, у дерева есть определенные ответвления.
Ответвления Windows, ответвления Navigator, ответвления CSS далеко не все представлены здесь в моем чекере.
То есть у меня здесь менее чем полторы...
Ну, около полутора тысяч параметров.
И всего из 16 тысяч.
Я не стал заморачиваться на этом долго, потому что логика, в принципе, одна и та же.
Получить максимум.
То есть все, что только можно получить с ПК-пользователя.
Затем, после того, как были получены эти фактически 16 тысяч различных параметров,
в которые входит, например, размер вашего окна, DPI вашего монитора, разрешение монитора, например.
Все, что только можно себе представить, вот все, что собирает у вас браузер, вот то же самое видят и веб-ресурсы.
Ну, в большей степени, скажем так.
Затем это все разделяется на определенные ветви.
И каждая из этих ветвей, она приводит...
Приводит к определенному значению, которое затем хэшируется.
То есть, например, вот у нас все, что касается перфоманса.
В моем случае это 22 основные метрики и 15 дополнительных метрик.
То есть всего у нас сколько здесь?
37 различных метрик, которые относятся к перфомансу.
При этом, повторюсь, у меня здесь представлены еще далеко не все.
Благодаря этому около 16 тысяч атрибутов.
Как и написано в шапке у меня.
Около 16 тысяч атрибутов позволяют создать невероятно точный отпечаток.
Который подвержен так называемой процедуре фази хэширования.
Что означает процедура фази хэширования?
Она означает то, что если в этом отпечатке, как мы с вами понимаем, как отпечаток составляется.
То есть, если изменить какое-то одно значение, то, соответственно, изменится и сам отпечаток.
Но в данном случае...
Так не работает, потому что при составлении одного единого отпечатка, применяется процедура фази хэширования.
То есть, есть возможность игнорировать до 30% изменений в этом отпечатке.
Соответственно, если вы задумали, что вы хотите, например, изменить размер окна или размер DPI, и у вас изменится отпечаток.
У вас ничего не получится, поскольку все остальные значения, они будут персистентными.
И, соответственно, когда будет происходить процедура поиска мультиаккаунтинга.
Поиска того же самого человека.
Она будет проходить как по общему отпечатку, так и по отпечатку с фази хэширования.
То есть, иными словами, будет поиск производиться по тому значению, которое было получено.
Вот в моем случае, например.
И значение, полученному без определенного количества данных.
Соответственно, таким образом, будет у пользователя два отпечатка.
Один основной, другой.
После процедуры фази хэширования.
Что позволяет добиться, на текущий момент, беспрецедентной точности в 99,7%.
То есть, фактически, повторюсь, что это такое?
Все, что можно, все данные, которые можно собрать с компьютера, они упакованы в одно единое решение.
Плюс к этому нужно сказать, почему компании в этом заинтересованы.
Потому что такая модель позволяет анализировать.
Вариабельность.
И храниться в 9 раз компактнее, чем обычный JSON.
То есть, невероятная экономия ресурсов.
Если мы говорим об одном человеке.
Это, в принципе, уже хорошо.
В 9 раз уменьшить все данные о нем.
Но, если мы говорим о, например, сотнях миллионов людей в день.
Как, например, Amazon, либо же Google.
То такие изменения в хранении данных.
Они являются чуть ли не ключевыми.
Потому что они позволяют экономить огромное количество средств и ресурсов, соответственно.
И плюс ко всему, это решение, ну, пример его вы можете увидеть сейчас на экране.
Что собирается, какие отпечатки.
То есть, вообще, абсолютно, совершенно все, что можно найти.
Любая новая технология, любой новый API, который появляется в браузере.
Будет перемещен, соответственно.
И будет отображен в технологии браузер FM.
А данная технология обладает огромнейшим датасетом.
И, фактически, она может работать сегментированно, независимо друг от друга.
Что это означает?
Это означает, что можно игнорировать определенные параметры для поиска кандидата.
То есть, когда у вас, например, произойдет замена.
Произойдет замена вашей видеокарты.
Обычные ресурсы, они, конечно же, вас будут считать новым человеком.
В то время как браузер FM не будет считать вас новым человеком.
Он сможет найти вас, игнорируя ветвь GPU.
Или же, пример, совершенно новый ПК.
Будет ли возможностью браузер FM идентифицировать вас, как пользователя нового компьютера.
Либо же вы будете известны уже как...
Скажем так, как уже участвующий в этой системе.
Нет.
Браузер FM сможет определить, что вы являетесь абсолютно новым пользователем.
То есть, то, что...
Я имею в виду не то, что новым для этой системы.
А новым в том плане, что вы полностью обновили свою систему.
Произвели переустановку операционной системы.
Изменили, например, обновили свой браузер и так далее.
То есть, браузер FM позволяет вычислить использование...
Переустановки операционной системы.
Конечно же, это может напрямую влиять и на использование виртуальных машин.
Но, повторюсь, поскольку браузер FM использует огромный конгломерат различного рода параметров.
Которые доступны с нашего ПК.
Параметры, которые относятся к железу.
Если они будут изменены, то, конечно, и обойти браузер FM не составляет в данном случае большого труда.
Но составляет труд что?
Составляет труд изменение самого вида вновь установленной виртуальной машины.
Или вновь установленной обычной машины.
Почему?
Потому что, например, если мы возьмем тот же самый сайт BrowserLeaks.
Вот мы обратимся к методике определения шрифтов.
Которые вы видите сейчас на экране.
Например, данные отпечатки, которые находятся у меня.
Они не являются виртуальными.
Они являются новыми.
То есть, иными словами, в данной операционной системе установлен определенный слой программного обеспечения.
А если же мы возьмем абсолютно новую машину.
Будь то виртуальная машина, будь то физическая машина.
Установим на нее новую операционную систему Windows.
То благодаря анализу тех же самых шрифтов мы можем определить языковую версию этой машины.
И будет ли она соответствовать тому региону, который мы заявляем.
Второе.
Мы можем определить, что машина является полностью чистой.
Помимо этого, мы можем определить использование специфического программного обеспечения.
Такого как Microsoft Office, Adobe Photoshop, например.
И так далее.
То есть, это нам дает, точнее, антифрод-системам.
Это дает возможность определить то, что мы являемся новым пользователем, бот-пользователем или легитимным пользователем.
То есть, даже банальная дополнительная установка шрифтов, которая используется в Microsoft Office.
Она уже помогает обойти множество метрик.
Это отчасти является и составляющей браузера FM по определению нашей новой машины.
Например, если мы только ее установили.
Плюс, конечно же, браузер FM использует энумерацию расширений для браузера.
То есть, сейчас редко где можно найти компьютер, на котором не установлен отблок, либо же юблок.
Какое-либо другое разрешение для расширения, для блокировки рекламы.
Важный довольно параметр.
Кстати, всякий случай.
Запомните, а то забудете.
Использование отблок в браузере крайне рекомендуется.
Крайне рекомендуется. Почему?
Потому что это является одним из важных признаков использования браузером реальным пользователем.
Так что обратите на это большое внимание.
Браузер FM.
Данный его код усеченный.
Будет доступен на сайте DetectExpert, а также в приложении к данному курсу.
Но, что хотелось бы сказать от себя.
Если мы говорим по поводу проблематики.
Проблематика работы с данным типом фингерпринтинга заключается в следующем.
При использовании вновь установленных ВПС, либо же удаленных серверов.
Есть возможность определения, что это новая операция.
Если используется Windows Server.
Есть возможность определить, что используется действительно серверная версия операционной системы.
Поэтому, если вдруг захотите по какой-то непонятной причине работать с серверами.
Ставьте домашнюю.
Далее.
Использование виртуальной машины.
Определяется великолепнейшим образом.
Вообще без каких-либо проблем в данном случае.
Использование антидетек браузеров.
Точно также.
Ну и самое главное, про что вообще призываю вас полностью забыть.
Это использование подмены юзер-агента.
Данная опция, она перестала быть актуальной еще в году, наверное, 2017.
И использовать ее сейчас, ну это просто полнейшего рода идиотизм.
Потому что определение использования реального браузера не составляет никакого труда.
Не только благодаря браузеру FM, например.
Либо же WASP фингерпринту, который мы изучали ранее.
Или благодаря технологии, которая была изобретена давным-давно.
Это аудиоконтекст.
Где у каждого движка браузера есть свой собственный отпечаток.
Но сейчас не об этом.
И продолжаем.
Вариаций использования данного программного продукта, браузер FM, есть огромное количество.
Но в первую очередь он будет проблематичен для пользователей мобильных телефонов.
Как ни странно.
И унификация есть.
То есть я имею в виду оборудование одно и то же.
Но тем не менее, благодаря свойствам операционной системы Android, определение пользователя не составляет никакого труда.
Даже несмотря на то, что не нужно даже устанавливать программное обеспечение.
Если сейчас метрики на мобильных браузерах, они слишком сильно отстают от метрик установленного программного обеспечения.
То благодаря браузеру FM есть возможность.
Полностью искоренить ситуацию и идентифицировать пользователя максимально четко.
Так что в ближайшее время ждите появления данного отпечатка на антифрауд системах.
Поскольку тесты его прошли великолепно и с большим успехом.
Техническая документация, если вас заинтересует, доступна в дополнительном файле, который вы можете найти вместе с этим уроком.
Также вы можете ознакомиться с исходным кодом данного чата.
Ну и проверить соответственно на своих ресурсах.
Также хочу обратить ваше внимание, что в данном чекере процедура фазы хеширования, которая может игнорировать некоторые ветки, она еще не реализована.
Ее довольно сложно реализовать, поэтому я не стал тратить на это несколько недель своего времени для того, чтобы показать как это будет.
Но я думаю, что в ближайшее время на сайте DetectExpert появится уже более продвинутая версия данного чека.
Такая, которая приближена к продакшену в существующих антифрауд системах.
И да не введут вас в заблуждение некоторые изменения, которые вы можете произвести путем манипуляции с свойствами навигатора или окна.
Поскольку, как я и говорил, изменение одного параметра, конечно же, может изменить и сам общий полный хеш.
Но не будет влиять на остальные ветви.
Которые также будут влиять на другие ветви.
Которые также будут подвержены анализу.
В частности, например, можно сделать следующим образом.
Ветка, например, Windows будет иметь меньший удельный вес, чем ветка Performance.
И в ветке Performance, когда собирается информация о производительности всех ваших устройств, которые можно получить с помощью браузера, будет иметь больший вес в построении отпечатка.
Чем, например, легкоизменяемая ветка Windows, либо же навигатор.
Спасибо за внимание. С вами был Vector T13.